est ce que vous êtes déjà posé des
questions sur la nature de l'univers
alors je parle pas d'un univers
abstraire je parle de notre univers
celui dans lequel on habite celui dans
lequel vous êtes vous est ce que vous
êtes déjà demandé de quoi était composé
votre corps l'air que vous respirez même
les chaises sur lesquelles vous êtes
assis si jamais la réponse est oui alors
vous êtes peut-être remarqué qu'il
existe autour de nous des indices qui
nous permette de déchiffrer un petit peu
tout ça par exemple si je prends mon
verre il y à de l'eau dedans et que je
vous lance dessus et hop à il y en a
quelques-uns qui s'écarte un petit peu
personne dans la salle ni nulle part sur
terre ne s'est dit que une fois lancé
l'eau qui volent va s'arrêter au milieu
faire demi tour et revenir dans mon
verre pourquoi parce que nous avons tous
l'intuition qu'il existe des lois dans
la nature et que ces lois ne peuvent pas
être violée
le but de la physique théorique c'est de
découvrir ces lois il faut admettre que
nous les humains est bon on est plutôt
bon pour faire ça je vous donne juste
une petite idée
depuis newton on peut décrire tout ce
qui se passe autour de nous le
comportement de tous les objets c'est
bon on sait faire mais depuis newton
on est allé un petit peu plus loin on
est même rentré dans un monde qui est au
delà de nos sens un monde dans lequel
notre intuition ne marche plus c'est un
monde merveilleux
vous allez voir en 1905 albert einstein
nous a appris que la lumière était faite
de petits paquets d'énergie des petits
paquets en latin ça se dit quant à skype
stan avait fait avec d'autres c'était
d'ouvrir un nouveau monde celui de la
mécanique quantique d'un physique
quantique le monde du minuscule le monde
des rayons lumineux mais voilà que
si je vous propose de vous projeter en
imaginaire en 1924 à paris il ya un
jeune scientifique français qui vient de
publier sa thèse il a 32 ans il
s'appelle louis de breuil et il affirme
quelque chose d'extraordinaire calculs à
l'appui il nous dit que finalement
lumière et matière cette lumière qui est
autour de nous et cette matière dont vos
corps sont faits ne sont pas si
différents que ça la matière elle-même
est faite de petits paquets d'énergie
donc la matière elle-même obéit aux lois
du monde quantique
rien que pour ça de braye a vécu le rêve
de tous les doctorants de la planète à
savoir recevoir sept ans plus tard le
prix nobel pour sa thèse c'est quand
même pas mal
un des pères fondateurs de la physique
quantique s'est immédiatement paraître
cette idée et il s'est mis cette tâche
d'essayer de découvrir grâce à ça le
fonctionnement de l'ensemble du monde du
tout petit et figurez-vous qu'il a
réussi il a trouvé une équation qui
s'appelle l'équation schrödinger qui
décrit la façon dont se comportent
toutes les particules de notre univers
ces îles il un petit peu fait si vous
voulez pour le monde du minuscule ce que
newton avait fait pour le monde qui nous
entoure si vous tirer une flèche newton
vous dit où elle va tomber
si vous lancez une particule est bien
chaude inger vous décrit ce qu'elle va
devenir donc de pau les particules dans
le monde du tout petit c'est pas comme
des flèches
c'est même pas comme des petites balles
il faut à la place qu imaginer une sorte
de nuage avec plein de mini bal partout
qui sont soit là soit pas là qui existe
qui n'existent pas sont superposés en
même temps et qui sont un petit peu
partout l'équation de schrödinger nous
décrit comment ce nuage là va évoluer
dans le temps et ce qu'il a trouvé est
extrêmement bizarre
pour vous donner une idée de ce que cela
voudrait dire dans notre monde à nous il
a conçu une expérience de pensée qui
s'appelle l'expérience du chat de
schrödinger l'expérience la voici dans
cette boîte
il ya un chat
il dormait peut-être un petit peu en
tout cas y'a jamais y'a pas que un char
il n'avait pas l'air très content parce
qu'à côté de lui je redis nga rami moi
aussi du coup une substance radioactive
alors une substance radioactive c'est
quoi si une substance qui peut se casser
en deux c'est pour ça qu'on vous a fait
signer une décharge aux premières ventes
parce que c'est radioactifs là dedans
c'est une substance qui peut se casser
en deux spontanément sans qu'on puisse
prévoir à l'avancé quand ça va avoir
lieu
donc il ya cette petite substance à
l'intérieur et celle que j'ai mise à une
chance sur deux de se casser de se
désintégrer entre maintenant et la fin
de l'expérience mais il a pas fait que
ça je crois ding à côté de cette petite
substance il a mis un dispositif aussi
ingénieux que sadique qui fait que si
jamais la substance se désintègre un
poison libéré et le cham heures si la
substance ne se désintègre pas le chat
est tranquille les lois de la physique
quantique nous disent que tant que j'ai
pas regardé à l'intérieur
tant que je n'ai pas ouvert la boîte la
substance radioactive s'est désintégré
et ne s'est pas désintégré en même temps
ce qui veut dire que le poison a été
libéré et n'a pas été libéré ce qui veut
dire que le chat à l'inter n'est donc
pas mort ou vivant mais mort et vivant
ça paraît complètement absurde je suis
d'accord avec vous mais c'est ce que
disent les maths
ils sont formels bixi les lois de la
physique quantique tels qu'on les
connaît sont valides schrödinger avec
son équation dit qu'il y à là dedans un
chat à la fois mort et vivant je vous
propose qu'on vérifie tout de suite
déjà il est pas mort c'est déjà bien
mais j avoue qu il n'y en avait qu'un
comme vous y attendiez peut-être vous
êtes peut-être aussi rassuré que le chat
soit vivant et non pas mort mais
figurez-vous que moi ça me perturbe
beaucoup qu'il n'y ait qu'un seul char à
l'intérieur parce que je crois aux maths
je crois à la physique est derrière et
si les maths disent qu'il devrait y
avoir deux chats à l'intérieur la
question s'est il est passé où le chat
mort il devrait être là il est pas il
est où
on peut croire ça aussi absurde mais des
scientifiques sont payés pour essayer de
répondre à cette question
et ils ont même été payé pendant des
années reading haras a fait cette
expérience de pensée il l'a publié en
pendant une dizaine d'années après ça
même presque 20 ans quasi tous les
scientifiques de la planète ont cherché
le chat mort jusqu'à ce que un jeune
américain du nom de hugues everett 3
arrive avec une solution complètement
hallucinante
il s'est dit que si einstein et de
bright ont raison ce qui semble être le
cas dont la matière et la lumière son
cantique notre univers entier effets de
matière et de lumière est absolument
aucune raison que l'univers tout entier
ne soit pas lui-même quantique est donc
une superposition d'états lui-même dans
lequel il ya plein de possibles ce qui
veut dire c'est que au moment où j'ai
ouvert la boîte les deux chats étaient
dedans avant et au moment où je les
ouvert notre univers tout entier s'est
scindée en deux
dans un des deux seuls dans lequel on
vivait nous le jette et vivant dans
l'autre le chat était mort cet univers
là c'est un univers parallèle au nôtre
qui va vivre sa vie advitam eternam
on m'a dit qu'à la fin d'un de ses cours
sur la physique quantique einstein a dit
à ses élèves
si vous m'avez compris c'est que j'ai
pas été clair
eh bien hugues everett 3 n'a pas eu le
prix nobel pour avoir publié ce papier
pour sa thèse
au contraire il a abandonné la physique
en se disant c'est n'importe quoi
pourtant il avait peut-être raison mais
pour vérifier sa son époque il aurait
fallu pouvoir voir des atomes un par un
les voir dans des états superposés et
les expérimentés et les regarder à son
époque
expérimentalement c'était complètement
exclue mais pas à notre époque
à la fin des années 1990 dans les
laboratoires de l'école normale à paris
l'équipe du professeur serge haroche a
réussi l'exploit de créer une expérience
dit du type chat de schrödinger pas avec
un chat mais avec des atomes des gros
atome et de la lumière
est ce qu'il a vu dans son expérience
c'est que les atomes étaient dans des
états superposés l'équivalent d'un chat
à la fois mort et vivant
il a même vu un de ces 2 et à
disparaître pendant l'essai plus qu'un
et données d'une certaine manière
naissance au monde auquel nous on est
habitué cette expérience-là lui a valu
il y a trois ans le prix nobel de
physique
on est parti de 1924 avec le prix nobel
de louis debré y on est arrivés en 2012
avec le prix nobel de serge haroche en
suivant une idée qui nous a fait
traverser une époque et des territoires
pourquoi est ce que je vous ai raconté
tout soit pourquoi est-ce qu'on a suivi
les élucubrations tous ces scientifiques
à moitié fou qui annonce que des chats
sur la fois mort et vivant qui a des
univers parallèles partout est ce que ça
nous sert à quelque chose
honnêtement je comprendrais très bien
que vous compreniez pas du tout pourquoi
on finance la recherche
mais il se trouve que vous auriez tort
des découvertes de deux breil et
l'équation de schrödinger sont nés tous
les objets que vous utilisez aujourd'hui
les ordinateurs les téléphones portables
les lasers quasiment tous les outils
médicaux vous pouvez trouver dans les
hôpitaux et la découverte darroch me
demanderez-vous eh bien figurez-vous que
elle donne la possibilité d'une
révolution industrielle technologique
réussissant avoir l'équivalent du chat
mort et vivant
il a ouvert la voie aux ordinateurs du
futur qui s'appelle les ordinateurs
quantiques un ordinateur quantique c'est
une machine qui utilise dans son coeur
la superposition des états des atomes me
suivait à grâce à ça ces petits atomes
et ces machines sont capables de faire
des calculs comme s'ils étaient
simultanément dans des milliards
d'univers parallèles ce qui veut dire
qu'un seul de ses ordinateurs la ferait
ressembler quasiment l'ensemble de tous
les ordinateurs qui ont aujourd'hui à
des bouliers ce serait aussi primitif
que ça la recherche fondamentale est une
est une discipline qui est assez
discrètes parfois même complètement
silencieuse pourtant elle est à la
source de révolution et les génies qui
sont derrière peuvent naître un petit
peu partout ici ou ailleurs je vous
donne juste un exemple serge haroche
celui dont on vient de parler est né à
casablanca au maroc
il est arrivé en france à l'âge de 12
ans donc une petite parenthèse si à
l'époque on avait fermé nos frontières
on aurait privé la france d'un prix
nobel de physique et ses potentielles
applications hallucinante
les connaissances scientifiques
appartiennent à absolument tout le monde
à vous à moi aux enfants qui naissent
ici aux enfants qui naissent ailleurs
c'est de notre devoir de les partager et
de transmettre c'est pour le bien tout
ce que je dis ça parce qu'il est fort
probable il est même tout à fait
possible que ce soit un enfant
d'ailleurs qui aujourd'hui tiennent dans
ses mains les clés de notre futur à nous
pas celui d'un univers parallèle je vous
remercie